schweizer erfolgsgeschichte präsentiert
die schweizer qualität überall auf der
welt
carolin forst das welt sind stickereien
mit ihnen erobert sie die welt hans
rudolf herren hat mit einer wespe das
leben von millionen menschen gerettet
und hoteldirektor simon rindlisbacher
wird in asien auf schweizer qualität
sie erzählen schweizer erfolgsgeschichte
grenzenlos gut
in der vietnamesischen hauptstadt hanoi
wird ein schweizer eines der großen fünf
sterne hotels doch simon rindlisbacher
ist im krisenmodus ich sehe gerade die
qatar airways ist zurück aber es
sinnvoll halte wir sollten sicherstellen
dass sie alle ein zimmer bekommen aber
wir haben nicht genug
sie müssen sich die zimmer teilen er
aber sie wollen das nicht
sie wollen das nicht die cabin crew ist
einverstanden aber die piloten nicht
dann machen wir es so als erstes gibt
dem captain dem co piloten und der
metro-tochter wien ein zimmer damit sie
sich zurückziehen können für die anderen
finden die eine lösung
ja das ist ein problem ist der flug an
ex minister kennt jetzt mit zwölf
stunden
es war bereits das 14 trockene aber wir
sind voll haus also voll gepackt und
deshalb machen wir sind vorbereitet so
dass der flug cancellara dieses problem
simon rindlisbacher war schon als
sekundarschüler in gossau von anzug und
fliege fasziniert
[Musik]
nach der hotelfachschule brachte er den
glanz der schweizer hotellerie erst nach
bangkok und später nach hanoi
[Musik]
egal ob das klappt mit dem falls die
gestrandete crew keine zimmer bekommt
muss sie in einem anderen hotel
untergebracht werden
das ist für rindlisbacher mit hohen
kosten verbunden sind sie okay wir haben
fünf zimmer die beiden piloten und drei
ladies bleiben hier die anderen gehen
ins forschen hotel
danke dass ich nicht selber zahlen
[Musik]
für hoteldirektor rindlisbacher ist die
bettenauslastung auch gradmesser seines
erfolgs ganz geschafft geht als ihnen
verraten
professor finde aber passiert ich
gestern bei klicken und jetzt schon der
prozent abschloss
da schnell gut und ich habe jetzt die
konkurrenzierung mit meinem freund von
magic 800 prozent der rache des native
wollen er ist sie immer zu wenig
verkauft kann aber je nach art der
sektion die konkurrenz der stickerei
boom ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
machte st gallen zu einer wohlhabenden
stadt eine unternehmerfamilie führt die
stück tradition bis heute weiter carolin
förster gehört zur vierten generation
mit ehemann patrick und der
achtmonatigen tochter elling wohnt sie
mitten in der altstadt
wirklich
wenn die mutter arbeiten geht bleibt
berlin bei der nanny
carolin wurde als jüngstes von vier
kindern in die familiendynastie forster
hineingeboren als co-ceo trägt sie ihre
kollektionen für damen unterwäsche in
die ganze welt hinaus mit spitzen
mäßigem erfolg
[Musik]
hallo wie geht's gut danke drei die
britin chance ist kreativchefin bei
triumph im archiv der firma forster
rohner sucht sie nach neuen
inspirationen dieser duft ich liebe ihn
bei der designerin fallen zwei
unscheinbare schachteln auf das ist der
unterschied zwischen uns briten und
schweizern schweizer sind sehr höflich
wir weniger
unglaublich braut pippa middleton zug in
stickereien von forster rohner alle
blicke auf sich
[Musik]
diese kreation schrieb gar
weltgeschichte andere design ring
[Musik]
für first lady michelle obama war bei
der amtseinsetzung ihres mannes das
beste gut genug kreationen aus st gallen
[Musik]
hier lagern sozusagen die kronjuwelen
des unternehmens über 600.000 textile
muster wurden innerhalb eines
jahrhunderts zusammengetragen die labs
archiv persönlich das ist natürlich
etwas was ihnen schmeckt sehr gut und
weiß genau gehalten
alle großen namen der tür haben mit den
st galler spitzen gearbeitet
[Musik]
es gibt noch weitere schätze und sie hat
dir vor ihrem sehen wir einfach von
ihren sponsoren überholen will also sind
halt auch sehr viel alles beinhalten in
der krone nachtigall frohsinn den links
und das ist wunderbar
nein das ist von 1957
das ist die posse pappa sehen die
luxuriöses der stickerei
das könnte passen ich kann nicht glauben
dass du das noch nie angezogen hast ich
würde mich daran quetschen
irgendwann
[Musik]
kilimanjaro kenia agrarforscher hans
rudolf herren und andrea schreiber
leiter von bio vision sind unterwegs zum
viktoriasee in kisumu heißt es vorerst
warten
sofort versucht sich der 71-jährige
herren mit der welt zu verbinden mit
einem seiner drei handys und telefoniert
das ist aber auch selber fehler
und diplomatie eigentlich merkwürdig
aber da muss natürlich anders machen
hans rudolf herren ist im wallis
aufgewachsen
er lernt der landwirt und wurde später
agrarforscher in afrika bewahrte er mit
biologischer schädlingsbekämpfung
millionen von menschen vor dem hungertod
und wurde mit den renommiertesten
preisen ausgezeichnet
ankunft am victoriasee dem größten
binnengewässer afrikas hier lebte und
arbeitete hans rudolf herren 26 jahre
lang seine forschung sollte ohne und
armut bekämpfen
bis heute ist er vom afrikanischen
kontinent und der widerstandskraft der
menschen hier beeindruckt sie und dass
das ist faszinierend wenn er würde die
unsere welt entwicklung stein war die
märkte beunruhigt sind die
forschungsstation icp audi am bau ist
das ziel
tja wie geht's danke dir gut kranke
geht's dir gut
begrüßt werden die schweizer vom
direktor der station cia kahn herren war
sein vorgänger er leitete dieses
institut neun jahre lang
ich bin neugierig von ihrem mentor habe
ich viel gutes über sie gehört hier
erforscht der herren wie
pflanzenschädlinge ohne einsatz von
chemie zu bekämpfen sind
es zählt also aus dem aussteigen in die
arbeit hans rudolf herren durchbruch war
in den 80er jahren damals zerstörte ein
schädling die man lockt pflanze mann
jack ist in afrika ein
grundnahrungsmittel ist rothe eine
katastrophe das ist der bösewicht die
schmieren aus ließ den mann jörg
absterben
diese schlupfwespe fand herren in
paraguay das insekt bord die schmier
lausanne legt eier ab die larven fressen
den wirt auf nach vielen widerständen
konnte der nützling nach afrika
importiert und dort gezüchtet werden
das bisher größte schädlingsbekämpfung
programm ohne einsatz von chemie war
erfolgreich und rettete millionen von
menschen vor dem verhungern
als erster schweizer erhielt herren den
welternährungs preis es folgte der right
livelihood award der alternative
nobelpreis die familie war oft an seiner
seite
auch die mächtigen ehrten ihn bill
clinton
prinz charles margaret thatcher und der
ehemalige us präsident jimmy carter
biologische schädlingsbekämpfung sei für
chemiekonzerne nicht lukrativ genug
methode vor schluss wohl nicht mit dem
business mit dem business wer täglich
korreliert mit der natur natur
bruderzwist ziehe um als erst mal
verstehen und brauche um wie sie
problems lösen einer natürlichen ordnung
wie ist also der planet menschheit auf
eine andere spur nachhaltige spur zu
bringen
ein feierabendbier mit andrea schreiber
dem leiter der stiftung bio vision die
herren gegründet hat die beiden arbeiten
eng zusammen
der hauptteil 24 stunden sieben tage die
woche führt davon überzeugt ist oder und
der gc keine arbeit und auch keines
relevant erwiesen
mit mit provision oder mit dem institut
aber nicht alleine
heute berät hans rudolf herren
regierungen beim aufbau einer
nachhaltigen landwirtschaft
[Musik]
im fünf sterne hotel in hanoi wohnen
nicht nur hotelgäste auch der direktor
lebt hier mit seiner familie anzug und
krawatte gehören zum seriösen auftritt
aber es gibt zwar eigentlich sehr
konservativ
[Musik]
einfach inzwischen gesucht
neben
ja
was gehört
so nah schien der nur asche gerufen wird
ist 11 jeden morgen bringt ihn ein bus
in die englischsprachige schule
[Musik]
dann verrät simon rindlisbacher sein
kleines geheimnis
ja das ist doch nichts wirkliches thema
ja gern seine wurde zerfahrener natur
und das ist warum das so ich bin mit
geheimnissen ich bin jetzt aber darum
die freiheit zur schweizer fahne ganz
rechte damit das land pro jahr mehr
gehör und wismar mich vor wenn die
zweite schweizer aber mehmedis zwischen
heimat und ein anderer habe die steine
der name habe die multikulti
[Musik]
carolin forster ist chefin von inter
spitzen textile kreationen für
damenunterwäsche treffen hier auf
futuristische spielreihen ein bh mit
led-lämpchen da er befürchtet also die
sage jetzt mal 13
traditionelle satz für die stickerei und
der bitte die technischen textilien
technische satz war richtig
[Musik]
der steg saal ist das herzstück des
unternehmens
hier entstehen edle kreationen für harry
potter und britta buchte ein exklusiver
einblick vieles darf nicht gezeigt
werden und ist geschäftsgeheimnis
[Musik]
mit ihrem ältesten bruder emanuel teilt
sich carolin die leitung der forster
rohner gruppe seine stickereien werden
von dior chanel und prada verarbeitet
[Applaus]
emanuel ist das älteste von vier kindern
carolin das jüngste sie sind die vierte
fauster generation vater orly war der
patron der traditionsfirma der ganze
also will ich halt die 27 uhr ruhig
die große frage ist wie rasch die sein
ist super
wer erfolg haben will muss in bewegung
bleiben
das gilt auch in hanoi
ok hätte so würde es so weitergeht
und heutzutage natürlich zum domingo
security officer
ok
zentrale bildschirm oder hinter jedem
stockwerk kamera überwachen und sorge
dass du alles laufe schon interessanter
hannelore genutzter der wechselrichter
schaffte also jetzt einmal david villa
den ball wie viel liter momentan zu
wenig ist
der saal wurde für ein elegantes die nie
gebucht
kein wunder also dass kein highlight
wenn es doch weil er sich mit bienen
noch im april
das ist so groß dass ich schnell dass
etwas großes bank hat das noch ab und
blickt das ist verrückt
so groß
fotos
[Musik]
seit dem abschluss der hotelfachschule
arbeitet rindlisbacher in südostasien
seinen blick entgeht nichts
sind es so schön verfällt mal geklärt
dass das c dass ich das hier ist doch
klar dass ich nach dem spiel für und axa
endlich kommt
ramona der versöhnungs chef guten abend
mit dem gemüse
bitte schauen sie dass das gemüse
perfekt ist etwas mehr den müsse es muss
gut aussehen
[Musik]
dankeschön
politische reise der hoch momentan also
ein exekutiv sous chef und manager und
deshalb das zeigt dass zum beispiel das
muss jetzt gemacht werden
[Musik]
dann wechselt rindlisbacher seinen hut
und wird vom hoteldirektor zum vater
j
sport1
sportlich war
wir sehen dann sprachraum
[Musik]
der vielbeschäftigte agrar ingenieur
hans rudolf herren reist fast jeden
monat von den usa in die schweiz nebst
geschäftsterminen steht jeweils auch ein
besuch bei seiner mutter in mondsee auf
dem programm
emma herren ist 98 und hat vier kinder
hans rudolf ist ihr einziger sohn per
skype haben die beiden regelmäßig
kontakt aber jetzt macht das ipad der
mutter probleme software aktualisierung
und dass man noch so update suchen
herren vater ist schon seit jahren tot
er war verwalter eine tabak plantage mit
seinem sohn war er überaus strengen
dass sie nicht machen ich habe frauen
sollen auch als mütter berufstätig sein
können
dafür engagiert sich carolin förster
[Musik]
darum hat sie diese kinderkrippe
zusammen mit ihrer schwester gegründet
[Musik]
soweit alles könne erledige sich nämlich
offen
revisionen storen schwester adrian hat
drei kinder und arbeitet als jurist in
teilzeit historische fabrik ist und mein
fachkraft ist aber nichtsdestotrotz bin
der meinung das ist nur möglich dass man
eben schafft oder karriere macht ihr
unternehmen und eltern für dieses ziel
arbeiten die beiden schwestern hier
ehrenamtlich den willen die gesellschaft
mitzugestalten hat carolin auch von
ihrer mutter mit auf den weg bekommen
[Musik]
die ehemalige fdp ständerätin erika
forster ist 75 und immer noch sehr aktiv
schrie bewegen und du sagst mir doch
noch unterschreiben
okay machen
ok messe firma aber letztlich wenig
kenne auch die mutter hat viel zu tun
und effizient - spannender zu machen da
sie an ihre das mit der politikerin und
mutter erika forster machten beide
reihen freude
willst du allein als extrem präsent die
liebevolle mutter ja ja ja es stimmt
märz verschickt sie im blut kann also
nicht das schon klar ort erleben wie
möglich bp aber in großer ganze extrem
wertvoll und wahnsinnig gern und mich
sehr dass sie einmal sogar mit den han
ja alles richtig gemacht
bis heute steht die mutter der tochter
mit rat und tat zur seite
[Musik]
für südostasien hat simon rindlisbacher
ein außergewöhnliches hobby ihn lockt
das glatteis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erstaunlich vermerken schoss noch rasche
nominierung nicht einfach
[Musik]
[Applaus]
super
vielleicht
mit seinen sportfreunden abzuhängen
gehört zum trainingsprogramm
sie sind experte simon
[Musik]
die nacht über in diesem fall spielen
stellen in ihrem prüfbericht vor
mit dem randstein ich sehe nicht mehr
dazu
[Musik]
200 kilometer von san francisco entfernt
liegt das capri wally es ist ein
kalifornisches weingebiete auch der
gelernte landwirt hans rudolf herren
baut wein an und er züchtet schafe
[Musik]
natürlich gedeiht hier alles ohne
einsatz von chemie eine solaranlage
produziert mehr strom als der hof
benötigt
[Musik]
herr ins ehefrau barbara ist biologin
sie hat sich auf wildbienen
spezialisiert zusammen haben sie drei
kinder
das paar hat sich vor 38 jahren an der
universität kennengelernt
unsere studien waren nicht so wichtig
wir arbeiteten in einem schäbigen
wohnwagen auf der forschungsstation in
bertlich
er mochte mich zu beginn nicht
sonderlich er mochte es gar nicht dass
ich das velo mit ins büro nahm dabei
aber recht und ausweise tagen übrigens
hat herren auch als winzer erfolg sein
wein wurde mit einer goldmedaille
ausgezeichnet
in paris ist carolin förster schon früh
morgens mit ihrem musterkoffer unterwegs
vier geschäftstermine stehen auf ihrer
agenda bevor sie im familienunternehmen
eingestiegen ist hat sie hier in paris
zehn monate bei chantelle gearbeitet
die geschäftsbeziehungen sind eng
[Musik]
die neue kollektion sind eben relativ
lange geschafft hatten starb das blöde
wie sie wird wer schützt uns nervt
einfach ins essen soll das seid ihr das
ist inter spitzen
sie haben die stickerei gemacht dass die
sind ja viele labore hat inter spitzen
auch in dieser saison den geschmack der
kunden getroffen jetzt gespannt ob es
gefällt oder anderen weiß sehr genau
dass sie entsprechend die erfahrung hat
gezeigt schweizer qualität kommt an
wichtigen richtigen moment und jetzt
eigentlich erfreut ist also gallier bis
zu dem moment in dem wirklich die
fertige produkt und mega cool
man könnte das mit etwas pflegeleichte
mischen ja ich denke ich es verstanden
[Musik]
was die zusammenarbeit ist sehr gut wir
sind sehr effizient sehr schnell wir
verstehen uns haben eine ähnliche kultur
unser gemeinsames verständnis ist sehr
hilfreich in der schweiz indes drei
küsschen
unser zuhörer bis bald und danke noch
interessieren
die nächste kundin wartet bereits
[Musik]
der koffer ist schwer
in kalifornien zeugen auszeichnungen von
den großen erfolgen von hans rudolf
herren als forscher hat er fast alles
erreicht und doch spürt seine frau
bisweilen den schatten seiner
vergangenheit
er hat es nicht leicht gehabt mit seinem
vater
er musste lernen zu überlegen schon früh
war ihm bewusst dass er allein ist wenn
er ein feld pflügen musste und irgendwo
das gras war kritisierte ihn sein vater
wenn er nicht sagte war es okay es ist
halt kein positives feedback zu bekommen
so hat hans rudolf herren schon früh
gelernt sich von der meinung anderer zu
lösen
einfach immer gemacht was ich denke dass
ich wichtig
[Musik]
an sich und seine fähigkeiten glauben
trotz widriger umstände
das war herren weg zum erfolg wie lange
dauert es bis zum flughafen
30 35 minuten ok der tag in paris ist
fast zu ende
wo sieht sich die geschäftsfrau in 20
jahren unheimlich lange zeit rum ist ein
business acht neffe und nichte den
contender oder vielleicht da wirken dir
was ist also das nicht so wichtig autor
ist einfach wieder gut und erzielte 24
sehen wir sie von adobe
ja
ihre reichhaltigen erfahrungen wird sie
dann wohl an die fünfte forster
generation weitergeben können
[Musik]
in hanoi genießt simon rindlisbacher
einen freien tag mit frau sohn und den
beiden söhnen aschi und aria vorstellen
wer schon immer zeigt karrieren und
vielleicht der familie wieder probieren
die familie lebt seit eineinhalb jahren
ehe
vorher war bangkok ihr zuhause
[Musik]
per zufall hoffen wo man in bangkok
selber noch eine chance geben
endlos länder um viel teils mit mitte
land vernichtet und sie schätzten im
moment schafft und den hat sie mal mein
tisch haut als ich ihn das erste mal
begegnete spürte ich er ist sehr höflich
und warm wie soll ich sagen er ist eine
warme person bin ich auf einmal derart
hoch
[Gelächter]
die beste party
[Musik]
seine kinder würde simon gerne in der
natur aufwachsen sehen aber in einer
stadt wie hannah ist das unmöglich
verträge laufen
der beschluss
das leben auf der straße
großes problem da er ein gutes
jobangebot bekommen hat zieht die
familie nun in die schweiz
[Musik]
nun hat bereits ein jahr in der schweiz
verbracht
ja wenn mein mann und unsere söhne
schweizerdeutsch sprechen
verstehe ich worüber sie sich
unterhalten
[Musik]
sie versteht zu viel das ist das problem
das ist gefährlich
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt und freue mich in die
schweiz zurückzukehren
für mich ist es auch sehr wichtig dass
mein mann dort wieder einen guten job
haben kann
nach 16 jahren südostasien wird sie nun
rindlisbacher campus manager an einer
schweizer hotelfachschule ich glaube es
ist vielleicht nach europa zieht
vermissen
russland aus
das neue abenteuer mit elektronischen
arie mit neuen freunden nahe liegt und
sie wieder beate ritter wieder und
wieder familie habe das ist fantastisch
so hat auch simon rindlisbacher mit viel
leidenschaft energie und disziplin
seinen weg zu einem erfolgreichen lieben
gefunden
[Musik]
schweizer erfolgsgeschichte ist
präsentiert sich die schweizer qualität
überall war